ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález aumenta la
atención mundial por la sensación que
hay de un posible ataque a gran escala
de las fuerzas armadas rusas en el este
de ucrania en los últimos días las
tropas rusas se replegaron dejando en su
retirada de los suburbios de kiev una
estela de destrucción y de muerte según
las autoridades ucranianas la cifra de
víctimas civiles sólo en la ciudad de
lucha alcanza los 400 lo que hace pensar
que un ataque mayor podría ser
catastrófico para los ucranianos veamos
calles desoladas mientras ucrania se
prepara para un ataque inminente en la
región del donbass
pues el ejército ucraniano está listo no
podemos predecir cuándo sucederá
exactamente tenemos información de
fuentes occidentales dicho esto el
enemigo casi ha terminado la preparación
para la operación ofensiva de disney
westinghouse tanto kia como washington
han hecho la advertencia desde hace más
de una semana mientras que las tropas de
moscú se han fortalecido en el este tras
su retirada de la región de kiev así se
ha visto en ataques como el de la
estación de tren de crema torch o con
tanques recorriendo las calles de hbo el
novak a los combates se concentran en
mariupol la capital de facto del huv las
de donges que separatistas respaldados
por rusia señalaron que la ciudad
portuaria es uno de los principales
objetivos militares
el punto más candente sigue siendo
mariupol donde el enemigo ha concentrado
sus fuerzas en empresas industriales
el estado mayor general de las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas afirma que rusia está
intentando tomar el control de mariupol
mientras que el presidente mencionó a la
urbe para pedirle armas a corea del sur
dice aquí mariupol está destruida hay
decenas de miles de muertos pero aún así
los rusos no detienen la ofensiva
quieren hacer de mariupol un ejemplo que
puede dar software en el bus pocas
ocasiones nation en mixto
moscú por su parte sostiene que no
parará sus operaciones militares para
sentarse a negociar como dicen que sí lo
hicieron en la primera ronda de
conversaciones
después de que nos convencimos de que
los ucranianos no planeaban corresponder
se tomó la decisión de que durante las
próximas rondas de conversaciones no
habría pausa militar mientras no se
firme un acuerdo final es
moscú acusa a occidente de querer dañar
las conversaciones mientras refuerza su
presencia militar en el este de ucrania
bueno varios puntos para destacar además
de esta atención a nivel mundial por una
parte el poco motivador mensaje del
canciller de austria karl ni hammer
quien visitó moscú y tras un encuentro
con el presidente ruso vladimir putin no
dio un mensaje positivo incluso alertó
sobre este posible ataque
en general no tengo una impresión
optimista que pueda informarles de esta
conversación con el presidente putin y
ofensiva de los filis
evidentemente la ofensiva en el este de
ucrania se está preparando a gran escala
por lo que deje muy claro que se
necesita un acceso estable para la cruz
roja internacional de venice bueno eso
por un lado pero por el otro lado eeuu
se evalúa un supuesto ataque químico en
la ciudad de mariupol que sigue sin
confirmarse si esto llegara a ser cierto
qué consecuencias podría traer para
rusia para el presidente putin que
insiste en esas buenas intenciones y el
objetivo de la denominada operación
militar que sigue diciendo que son
buenas intenciones por parte del kremlin
con el pueblo ucraniano escuchemos si
los objetivos de la operación militar
especial en ucrania son absolutamente
claros y nobles lo dije desde el inicio
y quiero llamar su atención sobre eso en
mi primera declaración pública
dirigiéndome a la nación y a las fuerzas
armadas establecí claramente nuestros
objetivos el principal es ayudar a la
gente de bombas
según eeuu alexander bórtnikov es el
nuevo comandante ruso a cargo de la
guerra en ucrania dvornikov cuenta con
una amplia experiencia en este tipo de
operaciones después de haber estado en
la guerra en siria de otro lado en una
entrevista dada al diario italiano
corriere della sera' sergei carga nov
quien es el alto consejero del
presidente putin dijo abiertamente que
la guerra en ucrania es una guerra de
supervivencia contra occidente añadió
que espera que esta operación sirva para
transformar a la sociedad rusa en una
sociedad más militante basada en la
nacionalidad la actualidad y los hechos
recientes en ucrania y el rumbo que
puede tomar esta guerra en los próximos
días es nuestro tema de debate aquí en
france 24 para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a la doctora a nivel contra la
suárez 2 coordinadora de licenciatura de
negocios globales de la universidad
iberoamericana
la doctora contreras se encuentra en la
ciudad de méxico y desde buenos aires en
el sur del continente se une a esta
conversación andrés servín pont él es
analista internacional y director de la
coordinadora región de investigaciones
económicas y sociales a quien saludamos
entonces en la capital argentina pero
ustedes también los televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales estamos en facebook en
instagram y en twitter no se encuentran
como arroba france24 guión bajo s y
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo que la etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 deje todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas son muy
importantes para participar en este
debate comienzo entonces con la doctora
contreras dándole la bienvenida al
programa la salud allí en la ciudad de
mexico y comienzo preguntándole por en
ese nivel de incertidumbre que hay a
nivel internacional si estamos ante una
incursión militar rusa a gran escala en
el este de ucrania cuál es su
perspectiva al respecto
muchísimas gracias santiago por esta
gente invitación para poder compartir
con tu auto auditorio pues está este
mundo convulsionado y esta escalada que
día con día cada vez sube y aumenta como
un espiral sin duda la estrategia
militar por parte de las tropas rusas
pues es prácticamente poder aislar el
centro de ucrania es decir cuando vemos
lo que se ha desarrollado a lo largo de
todas estas semanas desde el día 1 de la
guerra pues ha iniciado o no su
incursión a territorio ucraniano primero
por el este luego también ingresó por el
sur se retiró de la capital de quién
pero cuando analizamos geográficamente
la ubicación de estas tropas rusas pues
es prácticamente
bloquear a ucrania del acceso al mar
negro y el mar de azov y de esa manera
tener un control absoluto santiago
principalmente de esta gran región que
es la de mayor interés por parte del
presidente vladimir putin lo que se
denomina como la región de dunbar sin
embargo hemos visto que cambio al norte
y al sur de donbass pues ha estado ahí
haciendo sus movimientos y sus
estrategias militares para
intentar tener control de mariupol pero
también de esta otra región al norte y
entonces estamos viendo que por un lado
a pesar de las bajas militares que tanto
del lado de ucrania como del lado de
rusia se registran de soldados
ucranianos y rusos finalmente estamos
viendo cómo esta escalada aumenta por la
geográficamente quieren tener el control
de todo lo que es la frontera con rusia
cambiar control territorial del lado de
la frontera común con rusia vamos a ver
qué piensa android ser bien en la ciudad
de buenos aires- estamos hablando de una
incursión andrés a gran escala hay temor
a nivel internacional o si todo palabras
del canciller ruso sérguei lávrov en su
momento que dijo antes de empezar la
incursión militar o la invasión al
territorio ucraniano que todo esto era
paranoia de occidente estamos en un
momento de paranoia de occidente o de
verdad tenemos que temer ante una
incursión militar a gran escala
bueno primero que todo me gracias por la
invitación
yo creo que están todos los indicadores
para pensar de que se viene una ofensiva
en el donbass el repliegue de tropa de
los trenes de los frentes que estaban
con tropas comprometidas o sea las que
venían desde el norte desde bielorrusia
las que habían avanzado sobre jarquín
estas unidades han ido replegando y
sanyo removilización la zona este de
ucrania justamente para fortalecer las
capacidades sobre el área de bombas
hemos visto unos despliegues de medios y
capacidades de crimea con eso lo que se
va a buscar hacer es consolidar el
control costero sobre el mar de azov
para ello la importancia en particular
de mariupol que va a ser el punto que
conecta toda la zona de crimea a la
costa con la zona de combate y
obviamente marie paule siendo no sólo un
puerto muy importante sino también un
centro metalúrgico clave para la
economía ucraniana entonces esto es lo
que va a hacer es permitir lo que busca
rusia es mostrar algún tipo de victoria
porque claramente no lograron esta
victoria en la toma de que no lograron
la toma de jarquín entonces les quiera
mostrar algún tipo de victoria
sería la consolidación de sus esfuerzos
en el donbass asegurando la
independencia de las repúblicas aparatos
separatistas y posiblemente la gran duda
si en algún momento van a tratar de
avanzar sobre o de ésta o incluso
iniciar una nueva ofensiva contra quiere
aunque sólo haya parece lejano una
ofensiva contra la capital también está
en el escenario aunque vemos a las
tropas rusas retirándose de los
suburbios de la capital ucraniana
continuó con android para hacer la ronda
a la inversa y le preguntó precisamente
por el puerto de mariupol un puerto
importante en el mar de azov que da paso
al estrecho de kerch y de ahí al mar
negro es una puerta muy importante pero
eso también tiene un valor estratégico
andrei y es que esto le permitiría a
rusia tener conexión por tierra con la
península de crimea si conecta toda esta
costa porque actualmente la única
conexión que hay con rusia es a través
de un puente en el estrecho de kerch
esto le permitiría estar primer y rusia-
conectadas por tierra porque mariupol
porque el presidente putin se ha
ensañado con este puerto más allá de lo
estratégico para dar como han dicho el
presidente es el en esquí un eje de sus
operaciones militares atacando civiles
dañando la infraestructura y
bombardeando la ciudad
a ver fue una de las primeras ciudades
atacadas junto con jarquín cuando se
iniciaron estas operaciones la
importancia más allá lo lo muy bien
señalado en términos del valor
estratégico y como conecta la región de
donbass con todo el sur de la costa
sobre gasol y con crimea es que
justamente alerce uno de los objetivos
primordiales de esta campaña militar
se vuelve importante para demostrar
algún tipo de victoria en particular
porque había una estimación por parte de
los rusos de cámara y pues
necesariamente se ha convertido en los
principales centros de resistencia al
contrario pensaban de que iba a ser
relativamente fácil de tomar de que iba
a caer justamente por la concentración
de fuerzas que iban a tener sobre bombas
las fuerzas que iban a avanzar desde
crime a la posibilidad de proyectar pues
fuerzas desde el mar entonces fue
inesperado este nivel de resistencia y
la verdad que dedicado una gran cantidad
de medios para tratar de tomar esta
ciudad por lo cual necesitan demostrar
esta victoria y de que esos esfuerzos no
fueron en vano hoy en día recibimos las
noticias de que cada vez el cerco sobre
las tropas ucranianas es mayor que se
estarían según algunos informes quedando
sin munición sin comida que varias
unidades estarían rindiendo por lo cual
puede ser de que en el corto plazo
veamos que los rusos logren tomar
mariupol además que es una ciudad que no
solamente ha estado bajo la mira de los
militares rusos ahora con esta guerra en
el este de ucrania desde el 2014 cuando
empezó todo el problema y la incursión
el tomba mariupol ya estaba en la mira y
fue varias veces atacada por las tropas
rusas continuó con la doctora contreras
en la ciudad de mexico
para preguntarle por esas palabras del
canciller de austria que veíamos al
principio del programa que visitó moscú
es uno de los pocos líderes occidentales
que ha podido hablar cara a cara con el
presidente putin y no salió de esta
reunión con un mensaje positivo su cara
pues lo dice prácticamente todo se está
agotando la diplomacia en este escenario
de la guerra doctora contreras la está
el presidente putin cerrando las
posibilidades de llegar a acuerdos a
través de la diplomacia de la
conversación del diálogo como lo ve
usted
muy interesante tu cuestionamiento
santiago porque me parece que la
diplomacia ya estaba de por sí
fracasando desde antes de que iniciara
esta guerra es importantísimo que sigan
los canales de comunicación abiertos con
rusia para poder avanzar en este diálogo
político y que finalmente en algún
momento podamos ver un acuerdo de paz
y visualizar que estas visitas pues
todavía y lamentablemente son fallidas
pues es una forma de que desde occidente
parecería o que quisieran que ya con una
visita esto se resuelva sin embargo
leyendo la comunicación política de
putin entendiendo la narrativa desde
rusia podemos visualizar que ellos lo
que quiere es llegar a un acuerdo con
ucrania no la intervención de occidente
que no la otan no esté más ingiriendo no
de ahí que se encendieron las alarmas
cuando finlandia apenas esto y estos
días anunció su intento por acelerar su
ingreso al otan que se ya se ha venido
dando desde semanas anteriores pero que
ahora se ha agudizado más en esto
también posibilidad de que ucrania pueda
acelerar su ingreso a la unión europea
sin embargo me parece que para que
podamos entender que si puede avanzar un
diálogo y que pueda haber un acuerdo de
paz más allá de lo que mediáticamente se
ha manejado de que el 9 de mayo por ser
una fecha emblemática como el día de la
victoria para rusia pudiera haber un
anuncio de victoria para esta nación me
parece importante avanzar en una
negociación pero rusia no busca que sea
de manera vil
es decir a veces algunas naciones hacen
un intento por que la diplomacia avance
pero a veces lejos de sumar restan y
aquí lo más importante es que el equipo
de negociación por parte de la educaciã
se si nuevamente se siente la mesa con
el equipo ruso para poder entender
llegar a poner sobre un lápiz y papel
como decimos aquí en méxico estas líneas
rojas que tanto ha exigido rusia como el
el reconocimiento de crimea como
territorio ruso el hecho de que ucrania
finalmente se comprometa el que sí haya
una neutralidad establecida en su
constitución lo cual sería el gran
compromiso de que no ingrese al dotar
también el hecho de que se desmilitarice
por completo y qué va a pasar con la
región de donbass ese es una todavía una
gran interrogante pero pareciera que
veremos un nuevo mapa geopolítico al
interior de ucrania donde estaría
dividiendo posiblemente entre esta
región de 2 y el resto del territorio
ucraniano
sí doctora contreras le pregunto sobre
ese escenario diplomático a nivel
internacional de lengua dar paso a
andrey para hablar sobre el tema de la
división del país pero quería
preguntarle a la doctora contreras sobre
uno puede entender que moscú no quiera
dialogar con eeuu sentado en la mesa box
viciando una mesa de diálogo con ucrania
que tal vez la unión europea tampoco sea
su interlocutor lo ha ignorado desde el
inicio del conflicto pero que hay de
países que sí son aliados que han hecho
un esfuerzo por sentar una mesa de
diálogo como por ejemplo turquía que es
un país bisagra entre oriente occidente
y es un país que ha jugado hay un papel
importante precisamente por los
intereses que turquía tiene en el mar
negro y lo importante que es ucrania a
nivel comercial para ellos
porque moscú no le abre las puertas a
países aliados como esos por ejemplo
bueno sin duda ahorita se ha estado
abierto a que turquía funge como
mediador pero sí como facilitador como
bien lo dijo el mandatario turco eslogan
ahora en la última
ronda de negociaciones que se dio en
estambul donde se abre la puerta de la
posibilidad donde existan continúan los
países abonando a un diálogo que
continúe la diplomacia y me parece que
aquí un rol importante santiago pudiera
ser el que se sume a permitir y
facilitar la diplomacia como pudiera ser
en china no pareciera que eeuu cuando se
acercó al gobierno de jinping pues era
en una búsqueda de poder despresurizar
este conflicto sin embargo
rusia lo dijo muy claramente hoy el
mandatario no putin cuando dijo russián
no se va a aislar es decir está abierto
a ver qué países se van a sumar más allá
de hungría y de bielorrusia y me parece
que ahí lo interesante va a ser de qué
manera si se puede abonar
que continúe este diálogo y que de esta
manera se pueda avanzar hacia una
negociación seria clara y concreta
santiago android hablábamos de esta
incursión y esta concentración de
operativos militares que podría haber en
los próximos días en la región del
donbass pensaría uno que teniendo las
tropas rusas ya en las puertas de la
ciudad de kiev
llevará la caída de la capital sería
como la cereza del pastel y ya llevaría
a una rendición de ucrania ante la
invasión de los rusos pero vemos que los
rusos se han retirado esto que dice que
rusia claramente no está interesado en
apoderarse de todo el territorio
ucraniano sino crear como una especie de
país colchón o bisagra que podrían ser
esas dos repúblicas del donbass dividida
ucrania en dos países diferentes y dejar
el centro y el oeste
independientes gobernados por kiev el
donbass de entre ellos dos y luego rusia
cuál es su análisis porque no entiende
uno porque se retiran de kiev si podría
ser el gran triunfo de los rusos
bueno el repliegue de la zona de quiet y
también la reducción de las ofensivas
porque la ciudad es jarquín responde en
una redefinición de los objetivos
estratégicos rusos antes limitaciones en
el ámbito operativo y táctico el avance
de quien listo es de jarquil se dieron
en los tiempos que se habían planificado
en los tiempos políticos no sea la
expectativa de que estas ciudades
caerían en los primeros días del
conflicto por lo cual también explica la
reticencia de parte de moscú de negociar
o hacer concesiones en la mesa de
negociación porque su expectativa
inicial era que con la caída de quien la
caída de jarquín iban a poder imponer
ellos las condiciones para una rendición
ucraniana y de ahí definir la paz en
base a sus propios términos al no darse
esto es que se ven obligados a replegar
sus tropas por las dificultades que se
implicaban y buscar una victoria
alternativa o por lo menos que pudieran
insertar dentro de su relato como una
victoria y que pudieran asegurar
entonces ahí el avance sobre bombas
donde había una menor concentración de
fuerzas ucranianas ya que éstas habían
sido derivadas para para defender aquí
dejar que
más el apoyo está existente de esta
región se ve como un plan mucho más
factible más más
factible en términos operativos de que
la puedan realizar las fuerzas armadas
rutas que sabían en sobreestimados sus
propias capacidades y subestimado las
capacidades ucranianas andrei usted ve a
ucrania dividida
a ver creo que desde la perspectiva
ucraniana si se consolida el control
territorial ruso sobre la región del
donbass con control de la costa sobre el
mar de azov creando este camino
terrestre conectando con crimea
desde la perspectiva obrera claramente
es una ucrania que está dividida por eso
también va a ser difícil aceptar estos
términos en el marco de una negociación
porque recordemos que la postura
refiero a en un futuro ver a ucrania
dividida en dos países distintos como lo
ha planteado moscú en algunos escenarios
y la intencionalidad de moscú apunta a
justamente buscar alternativas en
términos de demostrar algún tipo de
victoria no no lo veo factible en el
corto plazo porque no cumple ni con las
expectativas políticas que tiene el
gobierno ucraniano era el momento que
recordemos que la hora de negociar
también tiene que estar lidiando con sus
propias demandas a nivel doméstico este
tipo de escenarios no sería posible a
menos que sean netamente por una
imposición y lo único es que se llegue
hasta alguna instancia de este está el
fuego tiene una paz concreta en la cual
rusia impone algún tipo de control
territorial sobre esa parte del país e
impide que ucrania ejerza la soberanía
sobre esas regiones eso sí sería
probablemente un escenario más factible
que una negociación de repartición
territorial doctora contreras estamos
hablando que esta incursión militar de
rusia hace parte de una guerra declarada
de supervivencia si lo ha dicho el
kremlin contra el mundo occidental y así
lo ha dicho precisamente es el jey gaga
nov que es un alto consejero del
presidente putin lo dijo en una
entrevista ante un medio y también lo
dijo el canciller ruso en una rueda de
prensa en la ciudad de moscú esta
situación en ucrania esta guerra que
estamos viendo sería un primer paso de
moscú en esa lucha de supervivencia que
ellos dicen que están librando contra el
mundo occidental para romper la
hegemonía de eeuu europa está bajo
amenaza como lo ve usted
me parece que de entrada desde el
discurso de rusia su seguridad es la que
ha estado amenazada desde el punto de
vista de europa pues es la seguridad
europea la que se ha visto violentada
sin duda la estrategia desde el día uno
por el lado de esta invasión rusa el
territorio craneal no me parece que ha
sido a través de una estrategia de la
guerra de la resistencia es decir estoy
convencida de que vladimir putin sabía
el alto costo que iba a implicar desde
el momento en que curse jon harán sus
tropas a territorio
ucraniano porque era violentar la
soberanía de ese país y romper y violar
las reglas del derecho internacional
vladimir putin sabía perfectamente que
iba a tener un alto costo esta guerra
costo económico de sanciones puesto que
ya las vivía desde el año 2014
esto no es sorpresa para él y me parece
lo que si sea sorpresa que para
occidente les resulte novedoso no o sea
esto ya sabíamos que vladimir putin
aunque eso tejera y seguramente que
fuera una guerra que durará poco tiempo
él está dispuesto a resistir el tiempo
que sea necesario con tal de no
levantarse de la mesa con las manos
vacías santiago me parece que eso es
algo muy importante que occidente no
debe de creer que estará dispuesto a un
cese al fuego nada más así porque ya
haya un intento de intercambio de
palabras y de buenas intenciones músculo
ha dicho muy claro desde el kremlin que
se van a ir pero hasta que se lo den por
escrito y los acuerdos que lleguen entre
sí no tienen acuerdo vladimir putin
estará dispuesto aunque están gula es
economía y aunque se intente desde
occidente aislarlo avanzar al tiempo que
sea necesario
andrei en la ciudad de buenos aires-
mencionábamos los casos de suecia y de
finlandia países que han sido neutrales
tienen diferentes modos de neutralidad
pero así se han mantenido a lo largo del
siglo 20 y parte del siglo 21 pero ya
ambos han anunciado que podrían
formalizar su ingreso en la otan a
partir del mes de junio en el verano
boreal esto qué mensaje le manda moscú
qué consecuencias podría traer porque
moscú ya empezó a mandar también algunas
advertencias a estocolmo ya helsinki
claramente moscú está incómodo por
decirlo menos en cuanto a la posibilidad
de una nueva expansión de los 1000 de la
membresía de la otan justamente parte de
la retórica que tratan de utilizar para
justificar la intervención en ucrania es
esta el mensaje me parece que también
debemos entenderlo en términos de que la
guerra en ucrania confirmó los miedos
que tenían mucho en los países europeos
en torno a lo que perciben como una
política expansionista por parte de
rusia y una política expansionista que
es explicada como tal de forma abierta
recordemos que putin siempre se ha
referido
al
imperio ruso a la tragedia geopolítica
que implicó el colapso la unión
soviética
claramente percibe una rusia que debería
ejercer un mayor control territorial
sobre los estados satélites que los
rodean como medida para asegurar su
propia seguridad y esto es va a ser
percibido como una amenaza
para europa por eso también se explica
los aumentos que estamos viendo el
presupuesto militar de los países
europeos en inversión militar si todo
esto apunta que si veremos un incremento
en las tensiones porque claramente rusia
sobre todo putin no se va a quedar
tranquilo cuando se empieza a
profundizar este debate sobre la
incorporación de fuerza y de finlandia y
obviamente los países europeos tampoco
se van a quedar atrás en cuanto a la
retórica
discutiendo las posibilidades del
escalamiento de la conflictividad en
ambos países la que va a estar todo
acompañado este debate que estamos
viendo sobre el suministro de armas
ucraniano que además que finlandia y
rusia tienen una historia compartida
unos capítulos parecidos a los de
ucrania finlandia fue parte del imperio
ruso se independizó a raíz de la
revolución pero también fue parte del
imperio sueco tienen una historia
compartida y ya en su momento rusia
invadió a finlandia para tratar de
incorporarla a su territorio en la
guerra de invierno una guerra que perdió
la unión soviética y le garantizó a
finlandia permanecer como un país
neutral e independiente nos estamos
enfocando mucho en el tema de rusia pero
es lo que más ha destacado en los
últimos días en torno a este conflicto
quiero preguntarle a la doctor contreras
que pasemos un poco al otro lado de la
moneda y es el lado ucraniano lo que ha
pasado en los últimos días las
declaraciones que ha dado el presidente
selenski y por ejemplo esa cerrada de
puerta que le dio al presidente alemán
válter están malla que intentaba hacer
un viaje junto con los presidentes de
polonia y de las tres repúblicas
bálticas y el presidente selenski les
dijo no aquí aquí no van a venir ustedes
por ningún motivo sobre todo el
presidente alemán le cobraron de pasaron
factura de los alemanes al presidente
está en maya por haber apoyado el
proyecto del norte stream
bueno sin duda el tema del gasoducto
nord stream 2 se suma a a a estos
intereses geopolíticos no de ahí que por
eso alemania se ha resistido en
implementar un tipo de
cancelación de embargo hacia las
importaciones de este energético
proveniente desde rusia y me parece que
estos intereses geopolíticos justamente
son los que han prevalecido y hoy vemos
aún se le es que hay mucho más
fortalecido que al inicio de la guerra
porque le reclamo muchísimo al otan a
los miembros de que lo dejaron solo y
que entonces las promesas que le habían
hecho desde antes pues ya no era el
escenario que le habían prometido
entonces estaremos viendo que más
mandatarios europeos intentarán hacer lo
suyo pero realmente por intereses
individuales e intereses de cada país
pues no precisamente están alineados a
los intereses de ucrania y de ahí que
entonces estamos viendo os el esquí que
reclama también el tema de la ayuda
humanitaria la exigencia de la apertura
de corredores humanitarios pero también
la necesidad de un corredor azul que
esto es que se permita salir la gran
cantidad de 365 buques que están todavía
en el mar negro y que requieren salir
puesto que ya tampoco tienen alimentos
ni bebidas la tripulación pero al
interior de ucrania sucede lo mismo no
sé en qué es lo que está sucediendo con
los refugiados refugiados que han salido
a gran cantidad de países pero donde se
le es que lo que necesita es ayuda como
lo ha dicho desde alimentos medicinas
que entre la cruz roja internacional
para que pueda ayudar a los heridos pero
sobre todo lo que él exige pues son
armas para poder defenderse entonces
estamos viendo que este punto ahí es
donde yo digo vladimir putin está
ganando en el sentido nada más en ese
sentido de que está logrando fracturar
la posición de europa donde ya no todos
los países de la unión europea coinciden
no todos los países europeos tienen una
visión compartida y tampoco los países
miembros de la otan tienen las mismas
coincidencias y por tanto un cráneo pues
es el que se encuentra en el campo de
batalla día a día y es el que requiere
y a veces no me siguiendo sino
involucrándose se ayuda más que
intentando desde diferentes perspectivas
y abonar a través como el tuit y la
mente lo decías con estas visitas no
claro ya me queda pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa android que tanto
puede aguantar ucrania con este análisis
que hace la doctora contreras esta
fractura que hay que ya analiza del lado
europeo estas ayudas internacionales
esta necesidad del presidente se les
quiera hacer un llamado a la comunidad
internacional para fomentar la ayuda
humanitaria a los corredores la cruz
roja allí presente defender a los a los
civiles y estos y hacer investigaciones
en torno a estos posibles crímenes de
guerra y ataques químicos que tanto más
puede aguantar ucrania si esta guerra se
extiende tanto
bueno ucrania se ha demostrado
que ha sobrepasado las expectativas
iniciales sobre su capacidad de
resistencia el flujo de armas por parte
de los países europeos eeuu canadá
australia llegando a ucrania ha
consolidado parte de las capacidades
defensivas ucranianas y estamos viendo
que se está debatiendo mucho más el
suministro de armamento convencional
tanques vehículos blindados aviones en
combate llegaron sistemas de defensa
antiaérea de largo alcance desde
eslovaquia lo que también muestra que
hay una intención por parte de las
fuerzas armadas ucranianas de recuperar
sus capacidades convencionales
posiblemente pensando en la necesidad de
en un futuro realizar
contraofensiva de mayor de escala y
mayor contundencia por lo cual esto
muestra por lo menos cierta capacidad
consolidada defensiva en términos de
esta guerra de resistencia que
estuvieron llevando con rusia y
aprovechando justamente ciertas
simetrías para hacer la escuadra a su
favor y quizás viendo la posibilidad de
que el conflicto vaya mirando con un
enfoque sobre la región del donbass en
el que veamos confrontar convencional es
un poco más tradicionales o sean medios
blindados contra medios blindados apoyo
aéreo negación del espacio aéreo empleo
del sistema de defensa antiaérea sí por
lo cual parece estar bien parado a
ucrania en este momento habiendo pasado
tantas semanas el inicio de las
hostilidades y habiendo sufrido los
ataques que sufrió claro ustedes de un
minuto para finalizar el programa quiero
que hagamos las conclusiones que sigue
en este conflicto para los próximos días
cada semana hacemos un análisis de lo
que ocurre a lo largo de los últimos
siete días que puede pasar como lo ven
ustedes no tenemos bola de cristal para
ver el futuro pero desde el análisis que
ustedes puedan hacer comienzo con
android para el cierre
te diría que tenemos que estar atentos a
lo que pasa en armario porque
probablemente caiga el avance sobre ese
un va a ser clave para definir cómo se
lleva adelante la ofensiva en la región
del donbass y creo que esas dos ciudades
tienen que ir por lo menos a acaparar
nuestra atención en los próximos días
para ver cómo evoluciona el conflicto en
la zona este doctor a contra de las 30
segundos para el cierre
veremos más refugiados mayor impacto en
la economía global mayor alza de precios
en las materias primas como gramos
mentales y energéticos y lamentablemente
estaremos cada vez más cerca de una
recesión global donde la guerra todavía
no cesaran doctora maribel contreras y
andrei y servir pont muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate de france 24 haber hecho este
análisis para nuestra audiencia ustedes
pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y preguntas a través de las
redes sociales y por supuesto pueden
seguir en compañía de la programación de
france 24
[Música]